boeing is known for airplanes but they
actually have a long history in space
since nasa's beginning boeing has been a
contractor on every manned space program
including building the parts for the
international space station boeing has
been in human space flight from day one
and so it's just part of our core nasa
is hosting a competition for private
enterprise to build a spacecraft to
transport humans to the international
space station winning this contract with
cement dominance in the new space race
[Music]
we see this as just the next huge
opportunity for Boeing and for NASA how
big do you expect the market to be the
development price itself is such a huge
barrier just a very different business
model than Boeing's used to our huge
development programs are typically
centered around commercial airplanes and
military aircraft where there is a lot
of orders and right now foundation of
the business is two flights a year and
Boeing hopes that those flights will be
made in their cst-100 capsule they're
weld list design makes their craft
stronger and lighter than traditional
models already
how many astronauts will fly in this
capsule right now we've configured it to
fly up to five but the cst-100 is
designed for up to seven we have a
significant experience obviously in
capsules from mercury and Gemini Apollo
the capsule was was an easy decision
what about comfort this isn't exactly
the most comfortable position I've ever
been in no absolutely but because of the
potential with different anomalies you
could have a very rough landing we
needed to make sure that this design
would would satisfy even the roughest
potentially Chris Ferguson piloted
America's last shuttle and his new
mission is to get Boeing's commercial
space program off the ground this is the
simulator for the cst-100 yes this is
gonna be what we call our engineering
simulator how similar is commanding a
spaceship to piloting an airplane well
if you sit here and you look at this
concrete and say wow it looks like I'm
in a fighter airplane boeing has been
building fighter airplanes for decades
so we were able to take a lot of the
expertise and actually involve a lot of
the people who design these confidence
and make them a part of this right here
do you think that that lineage in
history gives Boeing a leg up over their
competitors I would like to think so
of course Boeing was the prime
contractor to build the space shuttle